zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
wir schaffen es nicht sagen die
pflegenden in den altersheimen und
kliniken in deutschland
es gibt viel zu viele ältere menschen
die sich mit corona infiziert haben sie
sind alt sie sind krank
sie haben angst und sie brauchen trost
und hilfe kaum etwas zeigt das so
anschaulich wie dieses bild hier
aufgenommen in einer klinik in texas in
amerika ende november ein chefarzt
tröstet einen alten mann der wegen
corona behandelt wird er weint weil er
isoliert ist und weil er zu seiner frau
nach hause möchte wie es heißt konnte
dieser mann inzwischen entlassen werden
aber wie es ihm ging und geht geht es
vielen menschen in den deutschen
altersheimen sie brauchen trost und nähe
aber sie müssen auch vor dem virus
geschützt werden eine
riesenherausforderung für alle die sich
um diese menschen kümmern für die
pflegenden für die angehörigen
und natürlich für die menschen selbst
darüber reden wir heute mit doris
schneider sie ist leiterin der caritas
altenheim in münchen schönen guten abend
frau schneider
schönen guten abend
frau schneider wie geht es ihnen
es geht so ich bin ziemlich auf der
einen seite immer angespannt was
passiert gerade in unseren häusern macht
mir viel kopfzerbrechen viele sorgen wie
geht es den bewohnerinnen und bewohner
aber vor allem auch wie geht es den
mitarbeitenden in unseren einrichtungen
in mitarbeitern in der pflege in der
hauswirtschaft in der sozial- begleitung
und vor allem auch denjenigen die die
verantwortung für die häuser tragen die
führungskräfte die seit neun monaten in
der korona pandemie tagtäglich
erinnerungen umsetzen müssen
die gratwanderung zwischen infektion und
der sorge um die bewohner den diskurs
mit den angehörigen über die schwierigen
situationen das ist einfach hoch
belasten psychisch belastenden
körperlich anstrengend und da sind viele
am ende ihrer kräfte und von daher mache
ich mir dann wiederum sorgen für unsere
27 altenheim
wie kommen wir jetzt über die
weihnachtstage wie kommen wir durch die
nächsten winter monate
frau schneider wenn sie dieses foto
sehen das kennen sie ja auch was macht
das mit ihnen wie wirkt das auf sie das
berührt mich sehr und es trifft sehr die
situation wie wir sie auch in unseren
häusern erleben
die bewohnerinnen und bewohner die bei
uns leben versorgt werden erleben seit
neun monaten eigentlich nur menschen mit
maske im gesicht das heißt kein lächeln
von den mitarbeitenden das zu ihnen
darüber kommt kein lächeln von ihren
eigenen angehörigen weil auch die
natürlich nur mit maske in die häuser
dürfen wir erleben viele situationen wo
wir bewohnerinnen und bewohner über tage
und wochen in ihrem zimmer isolieren
müssen weil sie entweder positiv sind
oder weil sie kontaktpersonen und sind
und unter verdacht stehen von daher
diese diese vereinsamung in den häusern
ist einfach ein wahnsinnig großes
problem wir können das normale soziale
leben des und so wichtig ist in den
häusern nicht anbieten keine
gruppenangebote oder nur sehr wenige in
sehr kleinen gruppen die gottesdienste
sind schwierig also alles was die
qualität in den häusern normalerweise
ausmachten mussten wir ganz massiv
zurückfahren und von da
ist es schon ein sehr einsames leben in
den häusern sehr sehr schwierig wir
blicken gleich noch mal speziell auf die
verschiedenen sachen mit denen in
verschiedenen herausforderungen mit
denen sie da zu kämpfen haben wir
schauen aber zuvor einmal in die heime
hinein wie sich die situation da
deutschlandweit darstellt und wir auch
die zahlen sind und wie hoch das risiko
für die menschen dort sich zu infizieren
nina niebergall fasst es zusammen
immer wieder gab es sie in den
vergangenen monaten diese meldungen
viele infizierte viele tote in alten und
pflegeheimen und sie werden immer mehr
trotz vorsichtsmaßnahmen wie etwa
schnelltests ältere menschen infizieren
sich insgesamt häufiger als der
durchschnitt
das zeigt ein blick auf die sieben tage
incidents die liegt vergangene woche für
ganz deutschland bei 183 für die 85 bis
89 jährigen bei 365 und bei den über 90
jährigen sogar bei 631 natürlich leben
die nicht alle in pflege oder
altenheimen einige aber schon dort
scheint nicht nur die gefahr sich zu
infizieren besonders groß sondern auch
an oder mit dem virus zu sterben in
berlin entfällt fast die hälfte aller
corona toten auf alten und
pflegeeinrichtungen in hessen waren es
ende november sogar zwei drittel
das leben im altenheim während dieser
pandemie ist es besonders gefährlich
[Musik]
tja das leben im altenheim frau
schneider wir haben hier verschiedene
fragen die uns über den über das
internet erreichen an dieser stelle
nochmal die herzliche aufforderung euro
fragen und kommentare wie immer in die
kommentarspalten oder wenn ihr die zdf-
heute- app nutzt bitte an diese e mail
adresse über facebook erreicht uns eine
frage von peter schmitz der fragt im
altersheim werden die insassen
eingesperrt aber die pfleger gehen jeden
tag nach hause und so weiter wie kann
das funktionieren frau schneider können
sie darauf direkt antworten also
zunächst mal werden nicht alle
bewohnerinnen und bewohner wir haben
keine insassen sondern wir haben
menschen die dort leben werden nicht
eingesperrt
grundsätzlich gilt erstmal für die genau
das gleiche recht wie für alle anderen
die dürfen raus wie sie wollen in den
garten oder auch weiter spazieren gehen
und dann gilt aber das gleiche ich
glaube ich wenn einer schneller darf ich
da direkt ein haag mal das ja ein
interessanter war und ist können sie
noch mal ganz kurz schildern wie ist
denn die die lage im moment in den
heimen dürfen die menschen nach draußen
ich weiß jedes bundesland hat seine
eigenen regeln eigene einzelne heime
machen auch ihre eigenen sachen aber
können sie für sie mal erklären was die
bewohner der heime im moment machen
dürfen wie der radius die möglichkeiten
da im moment sind bleiben wir erst mal
dabei das kann man gerne machen also
grundsätzlich der rechtlichen radios für
einen bewohner oder eine bewohnerin
eines altenheims ist genauso wie für
alle anderen
die dürfen das haus verlassen es gibt
keinen keine ausgangssperre die für ein
altenheim besonders gilt die dürfen
genauso rausgehen
andersrum dürfen sie nicht unbegrenzt
besucht werden aber es gibt keine
ausgangssperre außer natürlich dann wenn
jemand infiziert ist dann gilt
quarantäne genauso wie wenn sie oder ich
infiziert werden
das heißt also das ist ein weit
verbreiteter
die die situation ja auch gewesen die
viele noch vor augen haben vom ersten
lockdown im frühjahr und vielleicht
können sie dann nochmal erklären und
vielleicht vielen leuten auch die ängste
nehmen was besuchsrechte und
freiheitsrechte angeht denn es gibt
tatsächlich viele die glauben die
menschen sind eingesperrt die dürfen
nicht vor die tür und sie werden eben
auch ihrer grundrechte beraubt können
sie das nochmal aufgreifen
es gibt auf der einen seite den
gesetzlichen rahmen wo klar ist es gilt
dort genau das gleiche wie für alle
anderen auch die dürfen raus gehen so
wie sie das von früher auch gewohnt
waren wie gesagt andersherum ist es so
dass die besuchsrechte in den
unterschiedlichen ländern sehr sehr
unterschiedlich geregelt sind in bayern
ist es momentan so dass jeder bewohner
oder jede bewohnerin pro tag einen
besuch bekommen darf der muss wiederum
eine maske auf haben wenn er im haus ist
und er muss einen test vorliegen das ist
jetzt ganz neu sein letzter woche dass
nur noch menschen in die häuser dürfen
die einen relativ aktuellen test
vorlegen können oder von uns getestet
werden
dann gibt's natürlich situationen wenn
ein infektionsgeschehen im haus ist dann
ist es wiederum anders dann kann ein
kann eine gesamt quarantäne vom
gesundheitsamt über ein haus verhängt
werden oder auch über einen wohnbereich
dass es dann je nach je nach
ausbruchsgeschehen ganz ganz
unterschiedlich jetzt gibt es ja aber
das neue infektionsschutzgesetz und wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe steht da
drin dass einzelne personen oder gruppen
nicht vollständig isoliert werden dürfen
und ein mindestmaß an sozialen kontakten
erhalten bleiben muss wie ist denn das
herz wenn man in einem heim lebt aber
als ein infektionsgeschehen gibt
dann kann es natürlich passieren jedoch
die also wenn der der bewohner selber
infiziert ist dann ist klar dann muss er
oder sie im zimmer bleiben wird dort ein
quasi isoliert das ist aber ganz genau
so wie wenn ich infiziert wäre dann
müsste ich auch in meiner wohnung
bleiben dieses bisschen größer das muss
ich zugeben wie ein altenheim zimmer
aber der gleiche gelten die gleichen
regeln
es kann dann wiederum sein wenn auf
einem wohnbereich mehrere menschen
infiziert sind in der gruppe von 30
leuten vielleicht zehn bewohner
infiziert sind das dann tatsächlich dann
gelten aber auch diese bewohner wiederum
als kontaktperson einst so ist der
sprachgebrauch und werden auch quasi in
quarantäne geschickt da gilt auch
wiederum letztendlich das gleiche wie
für alle anderen menschen in deutschland
oder in bayern auch hier fragte 'wer ist
eines klar ist kumuliert sich ist ja für
die kumuliert sich natürlich in den
altenheimen das infektionsgeschehen hier
fragt ein user radfahrer ohne motor über
youtube können oder dürfen die bewohner
noch in gruppen am tisch sitzend für
aktivitäten wie spiel sport und
unterhaltung auch das ist natürlich
jetzt eingeschränkt also die großen
gruppen wir dürfen oder sollte natürlich
nicht in verschiedenen wohnbereichen die
bewohner mission weil dadurch wenn dann
eine infektion im hause ist dann ist sie
im ganzen haus gehen also wenn kein
größeres ausbruchsgeschehen ist dann
können die menschen nach wie vor auch in
kleinen gruppen mit den entsprechenden
abständen wie sie für uns auch gelten
gemeinsam essen und auch gemeinsam
spiele machen oder was auch immer
wenn dann wiederum ein
infektionsgeschehen in einem haus ist
muss man sehr genau hinschauen und da
wiederum einschränkungen machen die wir
aber jetzt immer nur möglichst kurz also
nur die maximal notwendige zeit und dann
auch wieder in den saal corona
normalbetrieb umstellen wenn wir uns das
foto vom eingang noch mal vor augen
führen
dann zeigt das ja und sie haben es
angesprochen wie wichtig nähe ist und
wie wichtig auch solche aktivitäten sind
wie von dem user gerade angesprochen
wie reagieren denn die bewohner ihrer
einmal darauf dass das jetzt alles nicht
mehr stattfindet und dass sie auch zum
teil isoliert werden müssen wie kommen
diese menschen damit klar
also natürlich ist es ganz
unterschiedlich wie die einzelnen
menschen reagieren habe ich krieg von
vielen bewohnern oder auch dann über
meine mitarbeiter wieder drücke spiegelt
das ist viele bewohnerinnen und bewohner
mit einer großen gelassenheit nehmen die
dann sagen na ja wir haben schon so viel
in unserem leben erlebt wir haben ein
dach über dem kopf ist es warm wir
kriegen was zu essen das stehe schon
durch trotzdem ist es natürlich gerade
für die menschen das muss man noch mal
besonders anschauen die an demenz leiden
an demenz erkrankt sind und die die
gesamtsituation auch gar nicht mehr
verstehen können für die ist es
besonders schwierig weil wir da es
schwer ist die situation zu erklären und
es ihnen begreiflich zu machen jeden tag
manchmal wieder von vorne
ich gucke hier gerade so ein bisschen in
den chat und sehe dass das die leute
hier eifrig mitdiskutieren es gibt auch
viele fragen in richtung der pflegenden
dazu kommen wir auch gleich ich würde
nur eine frage gerne noch aufgreifen die
auch die ethische dimension klar macht
über das was wir hier reden hier fragt
ein user namens quebec über youtube alte
menschen sterben mit so einem smiley
hinten dran der sich kaputt lacht dabei
dieses argument wenn es denn eines ist
aber es wird von vielen menschen eben
einfach so dahin gesagt ja alte menschen
sterben halt das kann man auch nicht
verhindern dass würden sie auch tun wenn
es kein corona gäbe was antworten sie
denen
also ich glaube auch da muss man
differenziert hin habe man muss wissen
dass das durchschnittsalter wenn die
menschen zu uns kommen in ein altenheim
liegt bei ungefähr 86 oder 87 jahren und
natürlich ist oder inzwischen sind
altenheim er oft ein ort wo gestorben
wird man kann so sagen in der regel ein
drittel der bewohner und bewohnerinnen
eines hauses für sterben im jahr
von daher kann man das nicht ganz von
der hand
hunt vision aber das ist kein argument
nicht trotzdem die menschen die bei uns
leben zu schützen aber auch nicht so
weit zu schützen dass die lebensqualität
ganz heruntergefahren ist und das ist
eine totale gratwanderung die man jeden
tag auch wieder neu und in jeder
situation wieder neu entscheiden muss
und bewerten muss dann würde ich gerne
mal auf die mitarbeitenden blicken auf
die menschen die jeden tag ihre arbeit
in den heimen leisten und hier schreibt
auch jemand über youtube breit breit
ich arbeite auch im pflegeheim ich werde
seit monaten immer wieder gefragt ob wir
getestet werden mitarbeiter bei uns
jetzt nicht es ist wohl gerade in der
vorbereitung aber das denke ich seit
april
wie ist denn die situation mit den tests
und die den tests bei den mitarbeitern
aktuell bei ihnen also aktuell seit
letzter woche ist es in bayern so dass
die einrichtungen verpflichtet sind die
mitarbeitenden zweimal in der woche zu
testen war sich erstmal auch in der
theorie gut anhört und damit natürlich
das infektionsgeschehen eingedämmt
werden kann dass es sich einfach nicht
so weit verbreitet aber ist es wiederum
eine leistung die durch die
mitarbeitenden selber gemacht werden
mussten also mussten erst pflegekräfte
oder fachkräfte und hilfskräfte schulen
damit die diese abstriche machen können
und es ist ein irrer zeitaufwand der da
zweimal in der woche investiert werden
muss um diese testungen durchzuführen
also das ist von der politik gut gemeint
und die idee ist gut aber die
durchführung lastet wieder auf dem
personal das ja eh schon zu wenig ist ja
und genau zum stichwort personal gibt es
verschiedene fragen nämlich pit müller
schreibt über auch über youtube meine
frage wäre stellen sie zusätzlich
personal ein um alle personen die
getestet werden sollen zu testen wie
leisten sie das denn
wir sind seit wir das wissen das ist ja
gerne jetzt in dieser corona pandemie so
gewesen dass an dem einen tag wird aus
verkündet am nächsten tag oder
übernächsten tag müssen wir es umsetzen
wir suchen intensiv zusätzliche
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die
diese tests durchführen können
das ist aber auch nicht von heute auf
morgen zu bewältigen wir sind mit den
hilfsorganisationen im kontaktversuchen
vielschichtigen lösungsansätze um genau
diesen zusätzlichen personalaufwand auch
abzudecken aber wie gesagt das ist gar
nicht so leicht da auch an die
entsprechenden personen zu kommen
wie oft stellen sie sich die frage warum
man das nicht schon viel früher
angeleiert hat und warum man nicht
möglicherweise seit dem sommer auch die
bundeswehr einsetzt die ja auch
reiserückkehrer getestet hat nach den
ferien um vor den heimen zu testen und
nicht erst jetzt wo wir rekord
todeszahlen und rekord infektionszahlen
haben die frage die natürlich die stelle
ich mir immer wieder warum werden die
altenheime sind sehr in den medien
präsent das thema ist präsent aber die
tatsächliche unterstützung von der
politik mit personellen ressourcen die
waren früher schon immer auch
angekündigt wo die erste welle der
colonna pandemie war bei uns angekommen
sah ich nie was jetzt wird es wieder
zwar angekündigt aber die konkrete
umsetzung erfolgt nicht
es gibt den medizinischen dienst der
krankenkassen der normalerweise die
prüfungen die qualitätsprüfungen in den
einrichtungen macht das wären fachkräfte
ich weiß es nicht bis heute was die
eigentlich tun
die könnten zum beispiel wunderbar
testen oder uns auch in der einrichtung
unterstützen in der direkten pflege oder
wo auch immer
da fehlt einfach zwar
finanzierungszusagen also wir kriegen
finanzierungszusagen für das zusätzliche
personal zum beispiel zum testen aber
wir kriegen einfach konkret die
mitarbeiter und mitarbeiterinnen die das
fachlich auch können die kriegen wir
nicht her in der menge wie wir sie
bräuchten dann schauen wir uns mal an
was der gesundheitsminister dazu sagt er
hat sich gestern hier im zdf dazu
geäußert und der wiederum ist mit der
lage eigentlich insgesamt gar nicht so
unzufrieden
zuerst einmal seit april gibt es hygiene
besuchs
konzepte gibt es übrigens auch die
übernahme von kosten schutzausrüstung
und fb2 masken für die pflegeeinrichtung
und wir verbessern das natürlich immer
weiter aber sie müssen auch sehen von
den 18 millionen über 65 jährigen in
deutschland wohnen um die sieben 800.000
in den pflegeeinrichtungen viele viele
millionen leben zu hause leben in
familien haben darüber hinaus kontakt
und bei einer so hohen inzidenz einer
solchen infektion dynamik wie wir sie
aktuell in deutschland haben wird das
eben dann auch zur gefahr gerade für
diese älteren gut die eine frage ist die
nach den menschen die nicht in den
heimen leben das ist klar aber wir reden
ja jetzt über die andere gruppe wie gut
fühlen sie sich denn versorgt von ihrem
gesundheitsminister werden materiell gut
versorgt das war ja im früher durchaus
auch schwierig mit der ganzen
persönlichen schutzausrüstung das ist
inzwischen kein thema mehr das gelingt
uns die ausreichend zu bekommen wir
schaffen es auch die das material für
die schnelltests zu bekommen aber es
fehlt hinten und vorne an an personeller
unterstützung und auch manche dinge halt
so schnell entschieden werden die die
bringen uns echt an die grenzen wenn am
sonntag eine pressekonferenz ist wo
angekündigt wird jetzt müssen die
besucher zum beispiel mit testergebnis
kommen dann läuten bei uns am montag die
telefone heiß und wir wissen noch gar
nicht wie die verordnung ausschaut wie
wir sie umsetzen sollen
da werden manchmal ein bisschen mehr
zeit das ist klar in der pandemie ist es
pressiert jetzt alles aber es ist ein
wahnsinniger kraftaktes auch alles
umzusetzen heute waren wieder die
informationen zum thema impfen auch da
landet vielen organisationsaufwand
wieder bei den einrichtungen die mir
deutlich signalisieren jetzt sowohl die
mitarbeitenden als auch die
führungskräfte sie können einfach nicht
mehr
ich würde das thema impfen gerne noch
ein bisschen bisschen schieben hier in
der sendung und nochmal bei den tests
bleiben mit vielen die jetzt nicht
arbeiten können weil sie zum beispiel
ihren job in der gastronomie im moment
nicht ausüben können als student zum
beispiel könnten die sich bei ihnen
melden und sagen ich melde mich
freiwillig
macht diese tests oder was verbirgt sich
hinter der formulierung medizinisch
geschultes personal das ist eine gute
frage die schwierig zu beantworten ist
dann heißt sondern eher die
einrichtungen müssen irgendwie
entscheiden und verantworten welche mit
arbeiten des machen
wir haben das schon ausgeweitet auf
menschen die zum beispiel pflege helfer
sind also nicht nur fachkräfte
sanitätshelfer medizinische studenten
aber es braucht einen gewissen eine
gewisse kenntnis um diese tests wirklich
gut und verlässlich durchzuführen aber
da ist auch vieles noch letztendlich
unklar und auch das wird dann auf die
einrichtungen abgeschoben zu sagen ja
ihr könnt das entscheiden aber die frage
dann was ist wenn fehler passieren es
ist ja auch ein eingriff in den körper
das ist gar nicht so einfach das auch zu
entscheiden wäre es dann wirklich machen
kann
am horizont ist es sichtbar dass wohl
die verordnung dazu noch einmal
aufgeweicht wird aber bis heute wissen
wir es nicht definitiv mit wem wir da
alles agieren könnten und wie gesagt es
ist schon man fährt ja sehr weit in den
rachen und in die nase hinein also es
kann jetzt nicht einfach jeder machen
etwa youtube schreibt uns ein user oder
eine userin namens pusteblume in
pusteblume looping wir arbeiten alle am
limit das offenbar auch jemand der in
der pflege arbeitet wir fachkräfte
machen die tests selbst dafür gibt es
kein zusätzliches personal
die angehörigen kommen weiterhin zu
besuch das pflegepersonal muss an der
haustür angemeldeten besuch abholen
belehren und zum test bitten zeit die
wir uns aus den fingern ziehen sollen
wenn ich sie richtig verstanden hat dann
ist das auch genau das was in ihren
heimen
der tenor unter den angestellten dort
ist oder ganz so nicht weil wir
tatsächlich zum beispiel für die
besuchsdienste zusätzliches personal
eingestellt haben wir wir suchen oder
wir haben über monate auch schon
zusätzliche ressourcen geschaffen aber
natürlich nie in dem umfang dass es
wirklich ausreichend ist aber wir haben
als träger und sehr bewusst entschieden
zu sagen wir nehmen das risiko auch in
kauf dass wir da auf kosten sitzen
bleiben weil es von anfang an klar war
dass diese pandemie sehr lange dauert
und wieder einfach unterstützen müssen
und nicht mit dem bisherigen personal
des stemmen können das ist jetzt nicht
unendlich aber zumindest das thema
besuchsdienste und manch andere sachen
versuchen wir nochmal abzufangen mit
zusätzlichen ressourcen auch aus anderen
bereichen des caritas-verbandes wir
haben ja ganz verschiedene einrichtungen
da die arbeit in den altenheimen
tatkräftig auch zu unterstützen
aber klar ist zusätzliches fachpersonal
ist auf dem markt einfach auch nicht zu
bekommen
eine frage habe ich noch zum thema
arbeitszeit es gibt verschiedene
bundesländer die lockern jetzt die
arbeitszeit regeln zum beispiel sachsen
da wird die sonn und feiertagsarbeit das
verbot wird aufgerufen die aufgehoben
die höchstarbeitszeit wird von acht auf
zwölf stunden täglich angehoben was ist
denn das für ein signal für die
pflegenden die sowieso schon am limit
arbeiten dass sie jetzt quasi noch
intensiver noch länger für das
wahrscheinlich nicht besonders viele
geld arbeiten dürfen also sonntagsarbeit
ist in der pflege schon immer natürlich
geboten weil wir am sonntag nicht zu
machen
längere schichten da gibt es auch ganz
unterschiedliche einschätzungen auch die
mitarbeitenden sind da
unterschiedlichste meinungen das ist
anstrengend das ist klar
das wäre für mich nur im notfall eine
eine maßnahme also wenn zum beispiel
eine ausbruch situation in einem haus
ist und wir hatten solche situationen
dass die hälfte der mannschaft entweder
selber krank und infiziert ist oder in
quarantäne ist dann muss man um die
bewohner noch überhaupt versorgen zu
können schon auch kreative lösungen an
stellen mir ist es aber immer wichtig zu
sagen es ist eine lange party
es liegen noch viele monate vor und von
daher auch immer wirklich zuschauen wie
kann ich die mannschaften vor ort
unterstützen und schauen dass die bis
mindestens ostern oder länger noch in
dieser pandemie durchhalten
nun ist natürlich wie sie es vorhin auch
schon angesprochen haben der impfstoff
eine ganz große hoffnung in der frage
wie lang dauert diese pandemie
wir reden gleich darüber wie das bei
ihnen dann auch vollzogen werden kann
und soll und schauen erst mal nach ich
glaube brandenburg nicola albrecht
hatten nämlich mal geschaut wie sich ein
heim schon mal darauf vorbereitet wie es
aussehen könnte wenn denn dann geimpft
wird
die 65 bewohnerinnen und bewohner des
senioren und pflegeheims im kleinen dorf
salo haben sich für die simulation zur
verfügung gestellt das team will
herausfinden wie viel zeit und personal
benötigt wird es geht um aufklärung also
das doch kann die infektion war viel
viel später abläuft als wenn sie
wirklich ungeschützt und es geht auch um
zustimmung
es ist ja relativ schwierig mit solchen
betagten die gratis aber auch
demenzkranke sind auch die einwilligung
in dieser situation zu bekommen
es sind die pflegerinnen und pfleger im
heim die die bewohner auf den impftag
vorbereiten
doch neben der hoffnung auf rückkehr zu
normalität und mehr kontakt gibt es auch
zweifel
[Musik]
und dann müssen noch diejenigen
eingeplant werden die bettlägerig oder
dement sind da müssen die angehörigen in
die entscheidung einbezogen werden
im team und pflegerinnen sind mit dem
probelauf zufrieden sie wissen nun einen
ganzen tag werden sie zum impfen hier
brauchen bis es losgehen kann gilt es
durchzuhalten
der frau schneider was bedeutet das
thema impfen für sie in der praktischen
umsetzung
wir haben uns heute gerade intensiv mit
dem thema impfung beschäftigt weil jetzt
endlich die ersten informationen auch
vorlegen das wird noch einmal ein
kraftakt sein der auch viel aufwand
wieder in den einrichtungen verursachten
wird wir müssen die bewohner informieren
wir müssen die angehörigen informieren
es werden im team sind die einrichtungen
kommen
die müssen begleitet werden es kann
nebenwirkungen bei den bewohnern geben
es gibt einfach wiederum ganz viel
gesprächsbedarf überzeugungsarbeit weil
natürlich hoffen wir dass möglichst
viele sich impfen lassen damit dass der
schutz dann auch wirklich greift aber
ich sehe schon meine führungskräfte vor
ort die sagen dass jetzt auch noch und
das jetzt vor weihnachten noch möglichst
schnell weil die die impf struktur ist
da und wenn der impfstoff jetzt
tatsächlich nächste woche in geringen
mengen kommt dann kann es passieren dass
wir über weihnachten dann plötzlich die
anfragen haben und die impfung noch
organisieren müssen obwohl wir
eigentlich ein bisschen schauen müssen
dass es auch für die bewohner ein
bisschen ein weihnachtsgefühl gibt der
dezember ist als starttermin im gespräch
wie ist das denn eigentlich wenn ich
würde sagen als starttermin der
impfungen aber da ist ja ein dauerlauf
notwendig und heute haben wir den den 17
dezember aber sie haben ja gerade schon
gesagt wie kurzfristig sie sich auch auf
die tests eingestellt haben also jetzt
wird man sich daran gewöhnen sich
kurzfristig auf impfungen einstellen zu
müssen zu einer zeit die natürlich eine
ganz besondere in diesem jahr ist frau
schneider was machen sie denn mit leuten
die sich nicht impfen lassen möchten
die heime müssen ja eine große
eine große hoffnung darauf setzen dass
alle geimpft sind damit man eben in den
heimen auch von diesen maßnahmen wieder
wegkommen kann
aber es gibt ja vielleicht auch leute
die sagen ich möchte das nicht wie geht
denn dann das heim damit um
also es wird keine impfpflicht geben und
natürlich werden wir auch
also wir hätten ja gar keine handhabung
wir werden weder einen heim vertrag
kündigen wenn sich jemand nicht impfen
lässt los sonstige maßnahmen ergreifen
wir können mal überzeugen können nur mit
argumenten überzeugen
die bewohner die angehörigen die
betreuerin dem thema begleiten aber mehr
können wir nicht machen müssen durch
überzeugungen und werbung schauen dass
wir möglichst viele menschen dazu
bringen dass sie sich impfen lassen und
es geht ja nicht nur für die
heimbewohner das ist auch bei den
mitarbeitenden die frage und in der
gesamtbevölkerung nur wenn der
gesamtbevölkerung auch eine gute im
quote erreicht wird werden wir überall
und damit auch in den altenheimen wieder
zu einer größeren normalität kommen
sie haben es gesagt in einer woche ist
weihnachten wie sie denn weihnachten in
ihren heimen aus ja weihnachten wird
dieses jahr auch in den altenheimen sehr
anders ausschauen wie sonst auch an
weihnachten gelten die besuchsregelung
die jetzt gelten das heißt jeder
bewohner kann maximal einen eine person
zu besuch bekommen das wird für viele
weil weihnachten natürlich gerade im
altenheim oft sehr emotionales die
bewohner sagen das ist vielleicht mein
letztes weihnachten oder auch die
angehörigen das wird nicht so schön sein
wie sonst ist keine große gemeinsame
weihnachtsfeier sondern halt auch wieder
nur in kleinen gruppen
aber es gibt viel kreativität in den
einrichtungen immer wieder zu überlegen
wie kann man die adventszeit gut
gestalten und von daher glaube ich auch
wenn nicht gerade ein großes
infektionsgeschehen an weihnachten
passieren und auch das kann uns in den
einrichtungen passieren dass dem virus
egal ob heiligabend ist dann wird es
natürlich ein besonders trauriges
weihnachten und das dann nicht nur für
die bewohner sondern auch für die
pflegenden die ja auch die
weihnachtsfeiertage im schichtdienst je
nachdem nicht zu hause bei ihr
familien verbringen sondern auch in den
heimen liebe frau schneider ich würde
ihnen gerne zum ende unseres gesprächs
noch etwas mitgeben was sich hier auch
in dem chat was viele viele userinnen
und user geäußert haben zb schreibt
jetzt sind sie weg wo sind sie denn
jetzt die lobes lopez aussagen auf den
rasen in münchen und auf die vielen
pflegenden ganz oben sind sie jetzt
gelandet und da gehören sie auch hin
robert biedermann schreibt über youtube
wir finden sie und die mitarbeiterinnen
in den caritas altenheimen machen einen
super job
das zum einen und anke teuer garten
schreibt über facebook ein dickes
kompliment an alle pflegerinnen und
pfleger und krankenschwestern die für
die menschen da sind
das tut hoffentlich nicht
diese ergebnisse das tut gut ganz
wichtig wäre es mir noch sind nicht nur
die pflegenden die pflegenden sind die
größte berufsgruppe in unseren häusern
aber es gibt ganz ganz viele mitarbeiter
in der hauswirtschaft in der
alltagsbegleitung in der verwaltung in
der haustechnik die werden immer
übersehen und die sind genauso wichtig
für das gelingen
in einem altenheim grad auch jetzt in
der korona pandemie und däne gilt
genauso vielen dank wie allen pflegenden
und mein gilt dank gilt an dieser stelle
ihnen liebe frau schneider vielen dank
dass sie sich zeit genommen haben trotz
der schwierigen situation heute abend
für uns hier und für die fragen und
kommentare der userinnen und user vielen
dank und auch ihnen trotz allem
fröhliche weihnachten und ihnen zu hause
vielen dank fürs mitmachen fürs mit
kommentieren mit fragen und mitschreiben
und ihnen und euch allen noch einen
schönen abend tschüss